welcome back to the road to 2000 as
always my name is Caleb ben b and i will
be your driver on this journey what I
wanted to talk about tonight is actually
planning in chess the first couple
lectures
I went over tactics tactical motifs how
to find them in your games and I think a
lot of people what they struggle with
next is how do I get there how do I get
to positions where I have tactics where
I can win material where I can win the
game so what I wanted to do today is
talk a little bit about planning so
planning is something that really comes
about mostly in closed structures there
are a few different types of centers and
chests and they kind of determine the
way that the play will will go so again
what I want to talk about today is a
closed Center so what what do I mean by
that basically what a closed Center is
is when all of these Center pawns are
locked together so they can't really
move its going to stay shut for most of
the game and you're gonna have to find a
way to play on the flanks so I'm sure
you guys have seen this pawn structure
before what opening would this maybe
arise out of yeah it's it's like a Kings
Indian structure so you can imagine you
know black has a bishop here White's
pieces are kind of develops in some
manner like this and we'll take a look
at that momentarily so this is one type
of closed center you can get this
position from the Kings Indian defense
you can probably transpose into it a
couple different ways smoothie from
imputes but it's one of the closed
center positions so we're gonna look at
a couple games in this and then I also
want to look at this structure today so
what type of structure is this right
what openings does does this come out of
yeah a French or a Cairo well not a
Carroll with with this pun still on the
board but you can transpose into you
know some care positions after something
like c5 c3 takes takes so these are kind
of two really common structures that
show up in a variety of openings one
being the French the other being you
know the Cairo and yet these types of
missions positions in the Cairo and the
piece placement will just be slightly
different so what should you
look for in both of these positions the
plans that each side has are actually
very similar in both of these close
center positions
what do you try to do in general yeah
you want to play on the side where you
have more space or sometimes it's
phrased play where your pawns points so
White's pawns are pointing you know to
the Kings side blacks pawns are pointing
to the Queen side so White's gonna try
to find play on the Kings side usually
and Black's gonna try to find play on
the Queen side and it's just the
opposite here here white has more space
on the Queen side so that's where he'll
try to play and black has more space on
the Kings side so I wanted to show you a
game that I played just a little bit ago
against actually Julian pearl Aiko who's
kind of famous on the YouTube channel
something you may know him and then I
wanted to show you a game that uh some
twenty four hundreds played and what the
difference is kind of where between our
games so this was a game in the King's
Indian so we're gonna see that first
structure again and let's see how it
went
you know maybe black went wrong
somewhere and we'll try to figure out
why white ended up winning or in this
case me it was a standard time control I
believe it was in a non Monday night
strong Swiss when that was still
happening I think Julian played in one
of those and I got paired up with them
so d4 Knight of 6 c4 g6 Knight c3 Bishop
g7 you for d6 so this is the standard
King's Indian this is the you know the
Orthodox variation some will say so you
can see how we've arrived already at
this same pawn structure that we looked
at up here right it's exactly the same
so again White's gonna play on the side
where it's more space meaning the Queen
side and blacks gonna play on the side
where he has more space meaning the
Kings side so with that in mind what do
you think our next few moves are gonna
be what am I going to be playing for
yeah I'm gonna be playing for you know
eventually the c5 break there are a few
ways to do it one popular way is the
the bayonet with beef or or you know the
the old way of doing it where you try to
play c5 without before and similarly
what is black going to be playing for
yeah
yet some way getting this Knight out of
out of the out of the way and then
playing f5 right so white plays inside
where he has more space and this shows
up specifically in this c5 breakthrough
you know attacking the base of the pawn
chain and black plays on the side where
he has more space and this you know
shows itself in the f5 breakthrough so
with that in mind I know blacks going to
attack my e pawn so I'm going to play
Knight e1 here and the point of this is
kind of twofold right I'm preparing to
defend my pawn with f3 and I'm
preventing this Knight from jumping into
any good squares so because of this
black really wants to play f5 anyways so
he plays Knight to d7 getting the knight
out of the way another move here for
black is simply Knight to e8 with the
same idea of playing f5 I develop my
bishop again aimed at the same plan
black plays f5 f3 and now F 4 so black
realizes my pawn is you know adequately
defended so he just gains even more
space on the Kings side and now what do
you think is his next pawn break is his
next bone break is gonna be excuse me so
I'll move my dis ship and now now what
should i quite be flying for has he just
gained his space over here and now he's
done or is you know is there another
another step to come
[Music]
yes so G 5 g 5n g 4 right G 4 is now the
pawn break that that black is paying for
so this is kind of what I wanted to show
in these close center positions so you
know more generally yes you want to play
in the side where you have more space
but in most of these openings that's
going to rely on a single pawn break and
you know if you can make that pawn break
then your position is very good if you
can't get that pawn break through then
your positions gonna have some some
problems so again you really want to
focus all of your play towards these
pawn breaks every move you make should
be with the purpose either the purpose
of advancing your own plan or preventing
your opponent's plan or ideally some
combination of the wolf with that in
mind splack played g5 you know advancing
his plan he's getting ready to to try to
play this my pieces are kind of set up
right now to prevent this as well as you
know even support my own play on the
Queen side so these two pieces are
pretty well placed because you know they
prevent my opponents plan and they
support my own plan this Bishop is well
placed it supports my c5 break this
Knight is you know it's on an okay
squirt but I can't really improve it
right now so with that in mind what do
you think the main moves here actually
are knowing that these pieces all can't
really be improved would you say yeah so
nice of d3 this is a very common move in
this opening you simply defend the c5
square and you know prepare to get this
pawn break through so that defense that
you know improves this piece in the game
I actually chose to improve my rook
instead of my knight so I played rip to
see one black plays Knight to g6 here
which is you know a very common move
he's bringing more pieces over to
support you know this advance on the
Kings side and now I play c5 so what do
you think about this move
just at first glance yes so there's a
reason to plate now instead of
supporting it more before isn't actually
the best way to support it if you want
to support the break you know more
thoroughly before you do it the way to
do it is with Knight d3 actually the
problem with be for is this a5 move
actually becomes quite good when it's
kind of awkward to defend this pawn you
can play a three but maybe you know
opening up the rook eventually isn't
going to be so pleasant so yeah actually
though you know slightly earlier on when
white was playing the system 93 was
almost always the move I believe this
was the most commonly played but lately
these days the c1 and c5 right away has
gained popularity and it doesn't make a
whole lot of sense at first right cuz
you know black can simply capture this
pawn
so would you agree that you know unless
there's a very important reason that we
played this right away you know this
doesn't make any sense at all yeah right
right I mean it kind of just looks
absurd at first because you know this
we've I've just talked up this point at
this point this point you know I gotta
be playing for c5 so I can take on d6 so
I can rip it open but the thing is c5
isn't actually yes it's aimed at you
know activating my own pieces where I
have more space but the main point of
this move is actually to prevent blacks
plan for as long as possible why would
that be how can that be the case yeah
that's exactly right so yeah the first
thing you mentioned was of course let's
say I do nothing let's just say I pass
for some reason black would love to have
this knight on f6 it puts pressure on
this epon and it supports this g4 break
f6 is like the ideal square for this
Knight
so the first thing it does is it draws
this night away from f6 where would like
to be then the second part you mentioned
is it makes the c7 pawn quite weak
actually because we've put our rook here
and now we've opened this file so
there's going to be some serious
problems for black on this c7 upon
unless he you know deals with it pretty
immediately and because of that we can
actually draw this Knight even further
away with this move b4 so now what would
happen on Knight to d7
yeah 97 95 and this games actually
almost completely over black is dead
boss Terra partially because I'm
threatening to actually win this rook my
force if he just continues with his plan
as he would like to do simply ninety
seven rook b8 Bishop a7 and there's no
way to save this piece so this would be
horrible for black because of that black
actually has to play Knight to a6 here
so now you know the pawn sacrifice kind
of makes a lot more sense we've given up
our C pawn yes but we've given ourselves
a target and we've managed to horribly
misplace black's knight now it's going
to be much much more difficult for black
to give this to you for me then yes so d
text e5 isn't actually a you know so
popular here I don't think this has ever
been played at a very high level I don't
know the specific lines to refute it
right away you get the feeling it might
just be something like Knight to d3
maybe b6 before right away it feels kind
of like a bit much
but I'm not sure what a what a better
move might be maybe before
I don't know about that Bishop c4 move
because again like I said this Bishop is
actually well placed because it does
really you know put a thorn in black
side with stopping this g4 break
but yeah Bishop c4 doesn't make some
sense setting up some threats but maybe
just king AJ it would be fine and then
you know g4 is coming all the well
that's the thing it's it's not so easy
you know I can play this h3 move install
for a bit maybe this before move isn't
isn't so bad I'm not entirely sure
though I'm not sure I'm gonna ask the
engine really quick so yeah thanks
before or 93 d6 yeah b4 is actually just
strong c4 Knight b2 and I'm just winning
my pawn back so this does get your
knight back into play but now I've you
know no longer giving up the pawn I can
recapture and you still can't play g4
right away you still have to like
prepare it a little bit mm-hmm so this
move isn't so great for black but it is
you know an important idea but you know
95 is the main move it's what most
people play again this b4 idea driving
the night to a6 and now I simply play
Knight to d3 defending this pawn
supporting this e5 square which although
I don't have a pawn to break through
anymore it's still important and you
know just developing my knight improving
my pieces so Rick to f7 was played
adding another defender here and maybe
preparing to you know support his pawn
break so again every move that you see
is with the purpose right it's with the
purpose of advancing my plan and you
know stopping my opponents plan and
that's the way you know it should be in
these clothes types of positions you
really have to play with the purpose
that's the only way I can phrase it
circa 7 I play Knight to b5 this now
puts pressure on blacks Queen side and
it's actually causing some very
uncomfortable problems for him in a few
games this move b6 has actually been
tried to save this pawn but uh
historically this actually hasn't gone
quite so well for black Wesley so
actually had a very
game where he you know eventually broke
through like this he just piled up on
the seat pond I think played something
like her to c3 and Queen to c2 and he
managed to break through so b6 is an
option here but you know it's not so
popular because it does give up a lot of
time right this is a full move solely
dedicated to slowing me down and it
doesn't do anything to help advance
blacks plan which is you know the main
idea so instead of that Bishop to d7 has
played this move is kind of directed at
the purpose of you know if if Knight to
a7 now my bishop is an attack that's
basically all black is trying to say
because this bishop is important because
again it controls the key square
you know the bishop helps the plan so we
have to keep the bishop so Bishop d7 I
actually played a four before taking on
a7 bishop f8 was played so this is
slowing me down supporting his weakness
and preparing to you know advance his
plan every move with a purpose
Knight takes a7 was played a rook g7
again just trying to prepare this so he
can play h5 and g4 now I play a kind of
strange-looking move Queen to b3 so why
is this move strange just should this
should kind of feel not quite right at
first glance
why is that
okay so yeah it kind of looks like it
doesn't have a purpose but it's actually
it looks actively detrimental if you've
been paying close attention that's
exactly right
I'm taking away a defender of the G for
square so this Queen was doing a very
important job defending G for and now
it's no longer doing that job so I had
to have a very good purpose to play this
move this is the way that a you know you
you really have to you know think before
you play a move like this because you
know in chess and be nice if every move
we play it always followed the plan but
sometimes you know you have to deviate
from the plan but when you do do that
you have to be very sure you know okay
this move has a distinct purpose with a
distinct threat with a distinct idea
that's going to make up for the fact
that I'm kind of ignoring my opponent's
plan so with that in mind thankfully I
did have a distinct purpose do you have
any idea what it might be planning this
Queen b3 idea this one was pretty tough
the deep on further up yes yes oh you're
you're almost there you're almost there
so you've got a good point let me ask
you what's the problem with me playing
b5 right here yes so that's true d6
would come with check but there's
actually a very big problem
white would love to play b5 here this is
the most natural move it follows the
plan you know it's it's advancing the
pawn but the problem is Knight to c5 is
actually just winning winning for black
because I'm going to take this
he'll recapture and now no matter what I
play this nights going to be taken right
my Knights simply stuck so the points is
after Queen b3 if black just follows
along with this plan now what what idea
do I have since my queen is better
placed here
something has changed about that final
position that we just saw I have one
extra option well maybe a couple extra
options but one really good one
yeah I don't think I don't think d6
quite makes a difference the idea I was
thinking of was Knight takes here pawn
takes and then actually this Knight to
c6 move and I thought this would be very
good for me so my knight does find an
escape thankfully and you know I can you
know get out of there
maybe d6 is also working as well I am
not so sure on this one King h8 your
idea was just to take here yeah maybe
but my Knights still stuck yeah my dad's
okay tanking c7 Queen c7 now I can play
b6 but okay where we get this and b6 v6
might be working there might be tactics
here yet yeah you have to be very very
careful though I wouldn't be surprised
if White had some tricky way out of this
involving knight c6 but yet this might
also win as well but the you know black
has ideas so I do like this this knight
c6 idea better maybe d6 works tactically
somehow I didn't see it we didn't find
it but I want to be surprised cuz 96 is
quite nice so this was my idea
unfortunately Julian's not that bad at
chess so he played King h8 simply
stepping out of all these ideas and now
for a second I thought you know maybe my
move isn't so great if black can just
you know play this one move in and step
out of it because I really would like to
have my Queen here but there was a way I
found to justify it in the game so the
move I played was a5 and the point is
now with this Queen here I'm supporting
this b5 push and then I will actually
play b6 know that I have an a pawn to
defend it so here my opponent made
this move Queen to be it what do you
think about this one yeah so already
it's one of those moves that you have to
say wow this is really you know this is
anti anti positional this is what we
would call anti positional because all
my ideas are going to be on this Kings
side I would love if I had my queen
ready to you know jump into the game I'm
actually blocking my rook off from you
know coming in further and I'm actually
blocking off my knight it's only Avenue
back to the Kings side which maybe
that's not gonna happen but it's
something to think about
so Queenie Queen to be a is anti
positional right it doesn't make any
sense
regarding blacks plan and because of
that maybe that's part of the reason why
tactics actually work out in my favor
here so you have to be very very careful
when you make these anti positional
moves that's kind of the point of this
game because you have to be very sure
that they come with a purpose and the
purpose actually works because more
often than not when you're moving pieces
away from where they should be
you might be thinking you're creating
threats but you're giving your opponent
more opportunities as well
with that in mind what do you think the
move is here
because if I do nothing he's probably
actually going to take this knife and
I'm not going to be so happy about that
so yeah so b5 is you know the first move
that comes to mind maybe the only move
so how does the line go b5 and then what
does what does black want to play there
so let's start with the the easy one so
be 595 what do we do this one's not so
hard yeah you simply take on c5 and play
a b6 as you said so uh yeah and then I
mean we're going to take this pawn we're
going to crash three on c7 and we're
going to win the game hopefully so black
needs something better than Knight c5
after b5 so you're thinking about rock
a7 how does that line possibly go so b5
work a seven what are we taking so
Bishop i7 Queen a7 is with check maybe
you don't care though maybe you're
playing b6 I'm not so sure that's true
you have to understand that if you're
playing Bishop a7 it's going to be you
know kind of a sacrifice to pieces for a
rook and you're trying to still break
through after that so b5 Rikai 7 do we
have any other options
yeah we can we can take the knight right
so B takes a six what does black play it
possibly rook takes a six Wow
you know it's it's unclear so let's
let's see what happened in the game
yeah that's exactly right so uh what we
were discussing was b5 Rick takes a
seven is really the only logical move
for black because obviously we talked
about Knight c5 b takes a6 regaining the
piece and now you would love to play
this move rook takes a six but we were
talking about a tactic here which
involves Knight takes e5 so the point is
if you recaptures we take here and the B
pawn is pinned to the Queen
unfortunately for black so because of
that black actually tried to you know
mix things up here but already I mean I
can comfortably say black is losing this
game and there are a couple of reasons
for that but I the main one is actually
just this Queen b8 move is simply a
terrible move so again you know actually
in some of these lions Queen b8 is a
move and Queen Bey does work and you
know there's a line where you know like
white gets something out of it like it's
something out of it so it might have
been an idea that he had seen before and
he was thinking okay maybe I'll just
play this idea I've seen in this opening
and it'll be fun but you do have to
understand that this is one of those
ideas that works under very very
specific circumstances and goes entirely
against the point of the opening so you
have to be absolutely certain about your
line before you play something like this
it's not something you can just play and
think okay attack is night he has to do
something and then I'll go from there so
this is a kind of the next step in
strategy right you find your plan and
you really want to stick to your plan
unless you find a very very good reason
not to
so yeah just we can see how the game
actually went b5 or k7b a6 that actually
happens now
black chart h5 so he's like kind of
realizing hey maybe I should stop
playing where my opponents plan is and
try to break through on my own but at
this point it's it's a bit too late in
the game I actually played king h1
because I'm a weak player and I was very
very afraid of being checkmated but uh
it turns out I can't actually just take
this rook
and be fine with giving up this diagonal
there's actually no real threats for
black which makes sense because he's
given up a lot of pieces but regardless
King age 1 White's still winning now he
actually does go for this Rick takes a 6
idea I again have this 97 move rook to
a8 what would be wrong with rook takes a
5
yeah so Rick a five-night takes either
g6 and g7 actually I think both are
working I like this one because it's
check rook takes and now we actually
have a nice tactic so Julian sees this
and plays RKA here I had to decide if I
wanted his bishop or his knight in the
game I chose his Bishop looking back
maybe the knight was the better piece
because because the knight has a nice
square on e5 but so regardless Knight
takes d7 or at 67 rook to be one simply
adding on pressure and now unfortunately
Julian made the blunder that kind of
ended the game he saw this tactic the
first time around but somehow missed it
here play a direct takes a five when of
course Queen c3 is winning the game and
he went on to play for a few more moves
but that part of the game isn't really
as important so yeah white went on to
win so any questions about that game you
know how black lost how black ended up
losing and why white was on the winning
end does all of that kind of make sense
yeah so the question is instead of
playing Bishop to d7
what if black allows Knight takes a 7
and tries to give up his rook for this
night right so maybe h5 is a natural
move yeah yeah we'll say we should fake
cuz that's what black ended up doing the
game eventually so I might play a four
first I will say rook g7 Knight takes a
7 Rick a7 Bishop a7
yes that's part of the reason why you
play the safe or move first is because
after b6 you have this this a5 idea so I
kind of break out I think there's
something else wrong with it
but it's not coming to mind immediately
so maybe it is just that this a5 idea
yeah
so since a5 is working so we don't play
b6 just h5 and yes so this is going to
accelerate your plan a little bit
but the problem is without this night
it's actually still extremely difficult
to get g4 in so I can play something
like h3 here if need be I can even bring
my knight back to f2 although that takes
away my bishops retreat so that would
kind of be a last resort
yes so maybe maybe blacks future plan is
something like Knight h8 z f7 but
there's actually another problem with
giving away the rook like this and the
thing is now my knight isn't stuck on a
7 so my plans actually come through a
lot more quickly because I have no
Knight that you're threatening to take
after Knight c5 so that means you would
have to play like Bishop d7 here so
after b5 you can play Knight to b8 and
this is just gonna go very very poorly
for black which I don't know any move
here Queen here forces like Bishop e8 I
think I'm not entirely sure but
something like this and you can tell you
know this is not a move black wants to
make because again it takes away from
his game plan and he's further away than
ever from achieving this I think you
overwhelming yeah yeah the overwhelming
majority of people do take the pawn on
c5 after white pushes c5 but I can check
the database right now I know I usually
face Knights e5 but yeah like maybe
something like 20 some games people have
chosen to ignore it and why it wins all
of them
but uh yes so strategically that's why
this sacrifice happens you know it kind
of slows down White's game plan in a way
because you're no longer taking on d6
but it does open up the file for your
pieces on the side where you have more
space and it slows down blacks plan and
then eventually you know black kind of
blinked first in a way he said okay okay
okay I'm afraid of all your pieces on
the queenside I'll play Queen b8 tried
to you know eject some of them or try to
you know take some of them when in fact
he should have just sucked his game plan
I think even up to this moment before
Queen b8 black is actually doing fine
here
a5 was actually I think a slight
technical mistake on my part just
because there there are better ways for
for me to play I think something like b5
here is actually still quite strong when
something like Knight c5 and don't
entirely remember the line but it goes
something like just sacrificing this
night for free for a full piece takes
and something like B takes or D takes I
want to say D takes and you know White's
pieces are simply going to be like way
too active and this is going to be
pretty good pretty good for white so if
I've kind of give them a chance to sneak
back in I'm not sure what the exact best
move is I want to say just h5 is is
gonna be okay for okay for uh for black
here something like B 595 Knight here
takes b6 takes takes maybe and already
g4 is coming so you can see you know
blacks plan would have been vastly
accelerated had he just stuck to this
his Queen can still come in to h4 a g5
his and I can jump into to h4 or f4 and
yeah so this is kind of how a black
should have played in my opinion and if
he had done this you know it would have
been an equal game still because neither
of us had really given up on our plans
yet with that in mind I want to look at
this game between 224 hundreds which
we're gonna look at it from the black
side actually and we're gonna see what
when you know whites kind of the one who
blinks first the one who makes the first
mistake
so d4 Knight of 6 c4 g6 it's the same
line in the Kings Indian actually we
have the same moves still Knight to d7
again 98 is another another wine and it
actually makes a lot of sense this 98
line thinking about this game we just
looked at specifically and why do you
think is that why does this make a lot
of sense considering what we just saw I
mean like what was all my play centered
around to the last game well yeah the c5
break but then once I sacrificed the C
pawn it was on c7 right that's where all
my you know counter-attacks were coming
from that's why he had to bring his
Knight to a6 so the idea of this 98 move
is kind of just I'm gonna defend c7 and
d6 you can open it up with c5 but you're
not gonna have as much counter play on
that Square specifically but Knight to
d7 was played instead in this game
Bishop e3
F 5 F 3 F 4 Bishop F 2 rook C 196 it's
actually the exact same position Knight
takes b4 96 93 wreck f7 Knight d5 Bishop
d7 a4 and h5 so this is the first
deviation from last game and the last
game black played Bishop f8 with the
idea of vert to g7 which is a fine idea
black simply chose to play h5 first in
this case so again white captured the
pawn as I did in my game now we see
Bishop to h6 so this is a different kind
of way of organizing the black pieces
maybe it makes actually slightly more
sense than the other game why do you
think that is why why do I say maybe the
bishop makes more sense on h6 then on f8
well sexual creates threat so yeah
that's exactly the point
Bishop f8 is more kind of trying to stop
White's plan approach you know it
defends this d6 pawn but in the last
game we saw that d6 wasn't ever really
the problem right the problems all came
you know on b7 and c7 so maybe it makes
more sense to put this bishop somewhere
where it can create threats like you
said so after is something like g4 if
the F pawn were ever to move
we could play f3 and their threats on
the rook threats on you know the
diagonal possibly and the bishop can
actually serve an active purpose white
played rook to c3 and this is the first
move that was kind of dubious it's been
played before but this move doesn't make
as much sense as some other ones so why
do you think why played it yeah it's a
little bit deeper than just stepping out
of this discovered attack and put yeah
but why this square specifically why not
rook c4 Roxy - or white rook c3
right okay yes so work see - would be a
big mistake but okay I mean rook c4 c4
is yeah you got me you got me
but okay rook c4 would be you know
another try white rook c3 into the Roxy
for that's fair that's fair
okay maybe c3 makes the most sense for a
lot of reasons but uh the idea I was
trying to get at is he's trying to stop
blacks counter play using the this Third
Reich defense this is the term that gets
used sometimes so maybe eventually
someday
obviously not right now blacks gonna try
to play like something like f3 and white
would like to bring the rook over
obviously this line is like nonsense but
this is kind of a deep point but the
thing is it's actually kind of a kind of
a slow way to play so instead of rook c3
what else do you think white could have
tried
yes so if I make some sense if I make
some sense but there's actually a
problem with a five yeah queen bee it's
good b5 ver k 7b a six rock a six now if
95
oh yeah the point is there's no pin in
the end that's right
so that was critical for this tactic to
work but instead there's this other idea
and this actually stems from the bishop
not being on f8 are the stems from the
bishop being on h6 instead I'm kind of
giving it away with my notation that's
good that's good so yeah how we're
things different with the bishop on a
fate no the bishops on h6
it's the most natural move for white to
want to play here well depending on how
you look at it my it might be completely
unnatural to you I have no way of
knowing but
Yeah right I mean this night looks dumb
I want to poke at it so I want to play
b5 and now that the bishop is on f8
after Knight c5 we can take take take
and our Knights defended and after
something like b6 what would happen
it's time for a there's there's Bishop
c4 in the end so it's like this other
line that I briefly mentioned in the
last game we play Knight to c6
if black wants to win the PC has to
capture now D takes we can insert this
if we want we don't have to and at the
end we're gonna play Bishop c4 and this
is actually going to be like I think
crushing for white if this line actually
happens so because of that because of
that black should play something
different here than p6 okay so b6 so
King g7 yeah um yeah simply takes check
I'll take this yeah it's it's not it's
not great yeah you might get this a for
pawn and maybe I have to keep this rook
on the back rank for fear and maybe
actually rook to be one here is most
accurate just stopping your rook from
coming in and yeah I mean it's plus
eight plus nine plus ya say this line
isn't so good and I might have given it
away on the board for half a second if
you're paying close attention but what
should black play here instead of b6
just g4 right away that's exactly right
and the line might go something like d6
trying to open up the same Bishop c4
tactic C takes D Queen takes D and yet
now this would actually be a very very
interesting game I'm not entirely sure
who's better here I don't completely
remember the details of this line but uh
scared for everybody that's very that's
very so uh I think it's yes it's it's
plus point five I mean what can you do
it's the Kings Indian why it's always
plus 0.5 but so yeah again the key is
not to start trying to just play on the
opposite side of the board trying to
stop your opponent you want to be making
moves that advance your plan and that's
why g4 is the correct move here so that
was a bit of a slide tangent however
because white didn't play b5 it's what
he should have done and said he played
rook to c3 which is you know kind of a
slower move this allows black simply
just played with g7 night to b5 what was
wrong with this move now after work g7
let's not spend too much time again but
and it is
any ideas so that the key is in the line
we looked at their wannabe Bishop c4
pinning the rook anymore
it would simply be check and black would
move and then black has more
compensation for a for the piece well
for the pawns some stud we seen ib5
trying to extract the knight Knight to
f8 preparing you know this idea
preparing this idea we see h3 trying to
prevent blacks plan Knight age 7 Bishop
e1 so white is fully committing to
trying to defend against this g4 brick
the point of this move is just to give
the knight f2 but again you see White's
progress is really slowed down on the
Queen side it's starting to look like
you know is white ever actually going to
make a threat on the Queen side or is he
just gonna try to stop g4 for the rest
of the game when of course you know
black eventually plays it as a sacrifice
and can break through so we see g4 takes
takes takes in 95 so this is a thematic
idea is putting this tonight on g5
behind this g4 break it attacks the
newly weakens epon and it prepares
something like f3 as well as you know
numerous other other ideas we see her to
c4 and this is kind of kind of the final
straw right you know white played rook
to c3 earlier instead of root to c4 and
now he's making this second move
seemingly wasting just an entire tempo
right which is something you don't
especially want to do in the King's
Indian it can lead to some disasters so
Burke to h7 was played getting on this
open file getting ready to create some
threats so once again black has
completed as pawn breaks this is kind of
a next step which we didn't really see
the next step in the previous game
because it ended rather quickly to a
tactic but once you've opened up the
side where you have more space once
you've completed your pawn break this is
where you know you try to just activate
your pieces and so what does that mean
that just means placing them on even
forward squares like this g5 Square
attacking the weaknesses that you
because you have more space and making
threats so this is kind of where you
start breaking through you start
creating threats trying to win the game
and this is where your tactics are going
to start popping up we see unite 2f2
holding on Queen f6 again he's just
bringing his pieces over to where he's
open the board Queen to b3 maybe he
could have tried to take this but I
somehow don't believe in it at all
bishop f8 preparing to checkmate
the White King Bishop d2 something
something like Bishop g4 Bishop a4 yeah
I guess Bishop a4 yes so takes here and
fails tactically to something like this
um yes oh maybe there's something better
maybe this is actually okay but yeah as
I said once you've broken through that's
when these tactics start occurring cuz
your opponent's gonna have to you know
make have some loose pieces have some
undefended pieces and your pieces are
gonna get active because you're playing
where you have more space so your pieces
will just naturally have more squares to
go to they'll be more active but uh okay
let's I don't know if we really want to
solve the mystery here
can I ask so yeah it's it's takes first
or no ninety-seven NERC c7 Bishop a4
Queen c1 and simply f3 breaking breaking
through
yeah also this bishop is now useful
right so okay so obviously white can't
take Queen to b3 let's turn that off
Bishop to f8 we already saw this Bishop
d2 simply Bishop to e7 this move
I don't immediately see the purpose
actually yeah that makes a lot of sense
you can you can bring this other again
or maybe you can bring this trick to f8
depending on the line but okay it's fine
we're 2 c1 we now see Queen h6 King f1
trying to avoid checkmate
Queen into h2 already you can see no
blacks pieces are just simply more
active and so they're going to be
tactics and whites King is is going to
fall one to c3
okay fate Bishop f3 preventing the f3
pawn brick now Queen g3 Bishop e1 rook
to h2 so threatening to capture here
possibly and on capture here what would
happen on something like 93 quickly
let's look
I don't know if there's an immediate one
actually at first glance it felt like
there should be but I don't know the
move I kind of want to play isn't it
takes f3 but it looks a little bit
absurd like a little bit too much
yeah simply maybe Quinn h2 here is is
enough and you're gonna take this next
turn and there'll be like f1 stuff and
king queen g2 stuff and yeah okay but uh
yeah
so Bishop d8 he simply defends the C
pawn in spite of everything going on but
this move is actually kind of inaccurate
believe it or not because you know well
I should just break through it doesn't
matter though either way you know black
is winning we see York to a three or
calf six bringing in the last rook Eric
c2h6 rook c1 and now Knight takes b4 and
this is kind of the the final
breakthrough we can just simply take
this pawn because after Bishop takes
after Bishop takes we have York H 1 H 1
in Newark D 1 and this is more than
enough so instead we saw Knight c7 which
one check anyways check queen h2 and now
white simply gives up his queen and the
game ended pretty quickly after
reasonably quickly after okay and yeah
here white went ahead and resigned since
totally winning for black in the Sun
game these funds are simply too much so
yeah any questions about what went wrong
in this game this one I think was even
maybe more clear because white kind of
just wasted some time right he didn't
play moves that advanced his plan and he
didn't like rook c3 maybe you can argue
it was aimed at you know slowing down
black but in the end it didn't really do
anything at all oh but yeah any
questions though any questions about
this one
all right so just to do a quick recap so
there are a few different types of pawn
centers today we were looking at closed
centers enclosed centers what you want
to do is you want to play on the side
where you have more space and you want
to play for a pawn break through on that
side in the Kings Indian which is what
we looked at today you want to play this
c5 move as white and this f5 f-4g for
break as black and when you're following
through on these plans it's very
important to play every move with a very
specific purpose aimed at furthering the
plan if a move doesn't further the plan
you better be very very sure that it's a
good move or else you'll find yourself
in trouble which is what happened in
these games other than that thanks for
coming out
thanks for joining me on youtube if
you're watching watching this online and
I'll see you next time
[Music]